mira los siguientes dos termómetros
identifica cuál de ellos tiene escalas
celsius y cuál fahrenheit y luego
etiqueta los puntos de ebullición y
congelación del agua en cada uno bueno
como pequeño recordatorio la escala
celsius es la que se usa en la mayoría
del mundo celsius celsius esta se usa en
la mayoría del mundo mayoría del mundo
del mundo y sabemos que le estamos
utilizando porque en esta escala a cero
grados el agua se congela bajo
condiciones ideales entonces este es el
punto de congelación del agua
congelación congelación del agua y a 100
grados a 100 grados el agua bulle el
agua hierve pues entonces aquí tenemos
bajo condiciones ideales el punto de
ebullición
y si vale entonces estoy acá es la
escala celsius pero también tenemos la
escala fahrenheit voy a ponerlo por acá
para rehn
suárez descontó parent
y está bueno y esta escala se utiliza
mucho menos solo se utiliza pues creo
que en eeuu belice jamaica y otros pocos
países bueno en esta escala tenemos que
a 32 grados a 32 grados fahrenheit bajo
condiciones ideales se congela el agua
aquí está el punto de congelación
congelación
y a 212 grados a 212 grados
hierve aquí tenemos el punto de
ebullición ebullición claro bajo
condiciones ideales vale entonces la
escala celsius tiene un poquito más de
lógica verdad como que fue hecha para
que en cero el agua se congele en 100 el
agua ebuya y eso suena un poco mejor que
fahrenheit pero igual se sigue
utilizando fahrenheit por tradición en
algunos países pero bueno ahora sí vamos
a ver cuál escala es cuál y para eso lo
que va a ser muy útil es recordar que el
agua hierve siempre en el mismo punto no
importa qué escala estemos usando es
decir debe haber una equivalencia entre
cero grados celsius o cero grados
centígrados y 32 grados fahrenheit
entonces qué sucedería si tenemos que el
de la izquierda de celsius pues
tendríamos que cero grados celsius
serían como pues como menos 18 grados
fahrenheit y eso no tiene sentido por lo
que acabo de decir así el de la derecha
tiene que ser celsius aquí tenemos el 0
y en efecto por aquí tenemos como 32
como 32 grados fahrenheit vale entonces
resulta que la
la de la derecha es celsius le voy a
poner aquí celsius
y la escala de la izquierda es
fahrenheit no voy a indicar de este lado
esta es farc
hyde con verdad fahrenheit ajá bueno
entonces ahí ya tenemos pues etiquetado
el punto de congelación del agua ahora
vamos con el punto de ebullición que de
paso nos va a servir para verificar que
estamos haciendo las cosas bien entonces
100 grados celsius deben ser
equivalentes a 200 grados fahrenheit y
en efecto si en esta escala marcamos el
100 entonces de este lado nos queda más
o menos el 212 vale el 212 entonces eso
confirma una vez más que a la derecha
tenemos celsius y a la izquierda tenemos
fahrenheit vale bueno nada más déjame
marcar con naranja esta escala de acá o
con rojo mejor con rojo entonces esta
escala es la escala de temperatura en
celsius y la de la izquierda que estoy
encerrando en naranja es la escala de
temperatura fahrenheit